[Müzik]
beni tanıyanlar bilir
fotoğraflarımı paylaşımlarda görenler de
sordu Neden böyle giyindin diye çünkü
Normalde ben böyle renkli rahat
elbiseler giymeyi ya da koşuyorsam
koşuşortu ve işte bir tişört de olmayı
severim ilk kez hayatımda ceket ve
gömlek giydim Hatta Smokin giydim onun
nedenini birazdan anlatacağım
Ben uzun yıllardır toplumsal cinsiyet
üzerine bir ders veriyorum bu sene 20
yılım bilgi üniversitesi'ndeyim ve bu
ders böyle çok heyecanla öğrencilerin
geldiği bir ders Çünkü
cinsiyet rollerini kodları konuşuyoruz
beden üzerine konuşuyoruz nereden
öğrendik nasıl oldu doğal olarak
düşündüğümüz her şeyi aslında bize nasıl
öğretildi bunları tartışıyoruz 14 hafta
boyunca bütün bunları konuştuktan sonra
dersin son günü diyorum ki evet Sevgili
dostlar Şimdi
öteki olarak düşündüğünüz
diyetin kostümüyle derse gelin lütfen
ne olduğunu tahmin edebiliyorsunuz
herhalde kadınlar benim gibi gidiyorlar
Bir işte belki ceket takım kiralıyorlar
sevgililerinden ödünç alıyorlar bir
yerlerden buluşturuyorlar geliyorlar
böyle gayet tırnak içinde erkeksi bir
görüntüde karşımda duruyorlar Erkekler
ne yapıyor derseniz çoğu zaten dersten
önce diyor ya hocam ya metroya bineceğiz
metrobüse bineceğiz nasıl olacak bu ya
mesela hiçbir kadın Bence ceketle nasıl
metrobüse bineceğim diye düşünmezken
erkekler bana hocam Yani şimdi ben
renkli bir şey giyeceğim oje süreceğim
metrobüste ne olacak diye soruyor Yo yo
diyorum metrobüsü falan hiç düşünmeyin
gelin Burada hep beraber giyinelim
onlara rağmen 20 senede Sevgili dostlar
bir öğrencim etekle derse gelmeyi
başardı bir Ee o da şu anda Zaten moda
sektöründe çalışan bir arkadaşımız Hani
zaten çok bütün çok açık biriydi
Onun dışında tek tük arada küpe taktım
oje sürdüm öğrencilerim geliyor
Bunun nedenini bugün biraz burada hep
beraber konuşuyor olacağız ve sizin de
beni dinlerken göstereceğim fotoğraflara
bakarken
kendinizde Bu neyin ne zaman nasıl
giymeliyim kadın olarak ne giyerim erkek
olarak ne giyerim Oğlan çocuğa ne hediye
alırım bunların biraz şekillenmesini ve
geriye doğru gidip bir bakmanızı rica
edeceğim şimdi ilk göstereceğim Pardon
Eee görsel bu beyefendi Eee Şans koti
diye Ee bir aristokrat aristokrat ama
aynı zamanda da lord'lar kamerasında
yani aristokrat varlıklı ve siyasetin
içinde yani düşünebileceğiniz en yüksek
erkeklik mertebelerinden birinde 18
yüzyılda yaşıyor beyefendi kıyafetinin
detaylarına bakmanızı rica ediyorum
özellikle ayakkabılarına
Ee böyle hani perde püskülünü andıran
şöyle güzel bir detayı var Ona da
bakmanızı rica ediyorum duruşuyla her
şeyle Ee dönemin Aslında ideal hekimolik
yani baskın erkekliğini temsil eden bir
beyefendi karşınızda duruyor
eşcinsel mi acaba diye sorabilirsiniz
aklınıza geldiyse ona da hemen cevap
vereyim Hayır değil Heteroseksüel bir
arkadaşımız 5 tane ilişkiden 12 tane
çocuğu var hatta böyle gene kendi
dönemindeki bir aristokratın eşini
baştan çıkarıyor Kadın onunla beraber
kaçıyor yani her açıdan hani en yüksek
mertebeye koyup koyabileceğiniz
Erkekliğin o zaman ki sembolü o zaman
erkeklik böyleydi
bugün benim dersime renkli bir gömlekle
getiremediğim öğrencilerim o dönemde
yaşasalar Charles gibi giyiniyor
olacaklardı şimdi çocuklara gelelim
çocuklar konusu hepimizin sanırım
aklında çünkü hani kendi çocukluğumuzu
belki hatırlamıyoruz etrafımızda
çocuklar var çocuklara hediye almayı
mutlaka gidiyorsunuzdur Ben gidiyorum
sürekli ve mavi ve Pembe'nin dışında bir
kıyafet bulmakta çok zorlanıyorsunuzdur
ben zorlanıyorum yani beyaz yeşil sarı
gibi renkler neredeyse yani %10-15
civarında ya da üzerinde kadınlar ya da
erkekliğe dair bir işaret olmayan düz
kıyafetler Ee gemiler koyuyorlar Bu
erkek işte bebekler koyuyorlar kız çocuk
Şimdi Bütün bunlar bizim ya Oğlan çocuğa
bu olur mu dediklerimiz onlar Biraz
nasıldı Ee onunla ilgili bir iki görsel
göstermek istiyorum size bir tanesi
gördüğünüz dergi kapağı Life dergisi ve
orada oturan
bebek diyeceğim
franklint Amerikan Başkanlığı yapmış
Frank Rose başkan olduktan sonra
çocukluk albümlerinden bu fotoğrafları
buluyorlar şimdi bakarsanız Hani bugün
böyle giydirsek çocuğumuzu kimse bir
oğlan çocuğu olduğunu düşünmez ama o
dönemlerde ki bu o dönemlerde dediğim
100 yıl öncesi bile değil
kız ve oğlan çocuklar beyaz elbiseler
giydirilerek Böyle insanların önüne
çıkarılıyordu ve fotoğrafları böyle
çekiliyordu tek hiçbir fark yoktu tek
kıyafet nerede dönüşüyordu Biliyor
musunuz çocuğun yaşı değiştikçe gene iki
kardeşim fotoğrafını görüyorsunuz Biri
kız biri oğlan
bebekler daha uzun giyiyor Çünkü
yürümüyorlar yürümeye başladıklarında
kıyafetin boyu biraz kısalıyor ama kız
ve oğlan çocuk arasında hiçbir fark yok
yine O botlu gördüğünüz şık
şapkasıyla 5 yaşında bir oğlan çocuğu
aşağıda gördüğünüz biri olan çocuğu
Neden pembe diyeceksiniz o dönemler
Çünkü Oğlan çocuğa uygun görülen renk
pembe neden Charles de pembe giyiyordu
hatırlayın Neden pembe Çünkü kan kırmızı
olduğu için ve savaşmak güç o dönem
kırmızıyla ilişkilendiği için
tekstilde de kırmızı elde edilmesi çok
zor bir renk olduğu için erkeğe layık
görülen bir renkti
Kırmızının böyle hafif bir tonu olan
pembe de olan çocuklar için uygundu
Şimdi ne oldu da bütün bu resim değişti
Bu benim kendime benzetmeye çalıştığım
donduraybır erkekliği diye bir şey
hayatımıza girdi
hatırlayacaksınız izleyenler vardır
madman dizisi
manhattan'da çok erkek bir dünyada
1960'larda geçiyor reklamcı bir grup
erkek viskilerin içiyorlar böyle hani
saçlar kıpırdamıyor demin Benim
mikrofonum takılırken Dedim aman Saçım
yerimden oynatmayın Çünkü taklit etmeye
çalıştım bu tür bir erkeklik nasıl
hayatımıza girdi Eee işte iş gibi bir
tanımımız olmaya başladıktan sonra
ofislere girdik ve ofiste eve erkek
ekmek getiren erkek gibi bir kalıbın
içine sokulmuş bir erkeklik karşımıza
çıkıyor yani o dönemin erkekliği
işe gidiyor ofiste böyle ciddi duruyor
gömleği var hiç kıpırdamıyor
ayakkabıları Çok ciddi ve eve ekmek ve o
onun ciddi olması gerektiğini de böyle
bir göstergesi yani ciddiyet ve
hegemonik erkeklik böyle üst üste bindi
ne ciddi değil renkli
süslü fırfırlı desenli bir anda erkeklik
bunları bir kenara bıraktı Peki Sevgili
dostlar kadınlara ne oldu şimdi erkeklik
böyle bir yere gidiyor ve güç bu
görüntüyle ilişkileniyorsa Tabii güçlü
konumlara geldiğini düşünen Kadınlar da
bu erkekliği taklit etmeye başladılar
Mesela bu görseller bizim Türkiye'deki
meclise girmiş ilk kadınlar dikkat
ederseniz aralarında Gömlekte kravatlı
olanlar bile var Neden Çünkü siz güç
Erkekliğin dünyası ve siz o dünyaya
girerken kabul görme amacıyla o erkeklik
performansını üstünüze yiyorsunuz
ve işte Mümkünse kravatta takıyorsunuz
ceket de giyiyorsunuz makyaj
yapmıyorsunuz belki topuklu
ayakkabılardan vazgeçiyorsunuz derdiniz
orada kabul görmek
Evet bu da benim Bugün sizinle oynamaya
çalıştığım küçük oyunu daha önce oynamış
olan çok sayıda kadının görseli ilk O
uzun boylu kadın ipten ilk çıkardığı
taksido modeli kadın için olan onu
giymiş onun reklamında görünen model
şimdi duruşlara bakmanızı Rica ediyorum
sevgili arkadaşlar oradaki duruşlarda da
bir tür erkeklik performansı var yani
sırf kostüm değil o beden diline bir
dikkat edin mesela juliendos'un pro'yu
tutuş pozisyonda ya da Merlin titreş'in
bakışlarına bakın orada da bir erkeklik
performansı olduğunu görüyorsunuz Hatta
bir kadının erkek gibi gene hep tırnak
içinde düşünün söylediklerimi giyinmesi
İngilizcede Power dressing yani Güçlü
Giyim güç göstergesi bir giyim anlamına
geliyor Sen erkek gibi giyindiğinde
Güçlü kuvvetli otoriter bir halde
oluyorsun Tabii günümüzde bile beyaz
yaka kadınların büyük bir kısmının halen
gömlek pantolon Hatta ceketle işe
gitmesinin nedeni bu özellikle ciddi
olarak tanımlanan iş alanlarında
çalışıyorsak Finans sektörü gibi oraya
böyle renkli çiçekli elbiselerle
gitmeniz pek hoş karşılanmıyor halen de
durum böyle Mesela Ankara kulislerinde
Eğer aranızda gidip gelenler varsa
Ankara kulislerinde halen ceketli
pantolonlu ya da etek ceketli gömlekli
kadınlar olmanız bekleniyor Çünkü
ciddiyet bu şekilde tanımlanıyor
ciddiyet mümkün olduğu kadar erkek gibi
olmak olarak halen tanımlanıyor
Şimdi gelelim renklere Eee Türkiye'de
maalesef
renkte dişil bir şey
yani rengin kendisi Ben futbol üzerinde
de çalışıyorum ve çok konuştuğum çok
keyifle tartıştım bir alan Çünkü halen
futbol hegemenlik Erkekliğin kalesidir
Türkiye'de de öyledir ve erkek adam
renkli takım tutmaz diye bir slogan var
Bu da biliyorsunuz Beşiktaş'ın rakipleri
olan Fenerbahçe ve Galatasaray'a karşı
kullandığı Biz siyah beyazız Biz erkeğiz
renkli giyinenler yeteri kadar erkek
değil anlamında
Şimdi burada Geldiğimiz noktada yani
charlescotty düşünün bundan 100 yıl önce
çocukların beyaz elbiselerle rugan
ayakkabılarla poz verdiğini ve gayet
erkek olarak
düşündüklerini düşünelim Bir Yüzyıl
içinde rengin kendisinin bile
kadınsı olarak kodlanması
peki buradan nasıl çıkacağız şimdi Itır
bugün buraya
smokin ile gelerek
cinsiyet üzerinde ne giyiyoruz ne
yapıyoruz hep beraber bir düşünelim diye
küçük bir oyun oynamak istedi ne yaptım
Aradım İstanbul'da nereden Smokin
bulabilirim çok keyifli bir dükkan
buldum Orada oradaki Gökhan Bey ile
benim kıyafetim tasarladık güldük
eğlendik buraya da geldim hiçbir sorun
yok Yolda böyle yürüdüm
tersini yapmaya çalışalım benim burada
sahneye çıkan sunuculuk yapan
dostlarımdan herhangi bir tanesi bugün
ben de böyle bir oyun oynayayım deyip
Bu gördüğünüz beyefendiler gibi ortadaki
de David Beckham'ın genç hali
hatırlayacaksınız Belki o görüntüyü
gelmeye kalksa ne olacaktı Öncelikle
gideceği tasarımcı büyük ihtimalle biraz
şaşıracaktı yani neden böyle bir şey
yapmak istiyorsunuz mesela benimle hiç
öyle bir diyalog bile geçmedi güldük
olabilir yani bir çıkmak isteyebilir ama
bir erkek sahneye Ben etekle çıkmak
istiyorum Hele renkli bir elbise ile
deseydi büyük ihtimalle bayağı şaşkınlık
uyandıracaktı ama bunu Sevgili dostlar
yalnızca beraber dönüştürebiliriz Yani
biz daha uzun yıllar erkeksi olmayı güç
sahibi olmak iktidar sahibi olmak olarak
bu şekilde kodlar ve giyimimizi de bu
şekilde şekillendirirsek bu cinsiyet
hiyerarşilerinden kurtulmamız çok zor
olacak yani kıyafet size çok basit bir
detay gibi gelebilir ama değil ne
giyiyorsak Aslında belli kodları
kalıpları kuralları yeniden yeniden
üretiyoruz Yani bir kadın ne kadar ceket
gömlek giyip iş görüşmesine gidiyorsa
Beni ciddiye anca erkek gibi olduğumda
alırsınız demiş oluyor ve karşı tarafta
böyle bir beklenti varsa da aynı şekilde
şimdi o yüzden bu oyunu erkeklerin dahil
olması gerekiyor Yani gördüğünüz gibi
bizim dahil olmamız çok kolay bu kadar
basit ne Metroda ne metrobüste hiçbir
yerde bize kötü bakılmıyor Aa enteresan
giyinmişsin deyip gülünip geçiliyor
ancak erkekler bu oyuna dahil olur ve o
cinsiyet kurallarını Zorlayacak
kostümlerle sokaklarda yürümeye
başlarlarsa O zaman işte kıyafetler
üzerinden yarardığımız bu
hiyerarşilerden kurtulacağız
etek yemek bir anda eminim Kolay
Olmayacak Benim öğrencilerim de giyemedi
bakın
Türkçe'de halen
Eğer bu olursa etek giyer Taksim'e
çıkarım diye bir biliyorsunuz
en büyük erkeklik kayıplarından biri
olarak kodlanabilecek bir söz var yani
etek giyip Taksime çıkmak bir erkeğin
başına gelebilecek en kötü şey olarak
halen Duyuyorum ben Siz de eminim
duyuyorsunuzdur birkaç sene önce de bir
iş insanı bu ifadeyi böyle çok rahat
doğal alanda söylemişti Tamam etek çok
zor eteği bir sonraki aşamalara
bırakalım ama İçimizden gelen renkler
yani çok basit en kolayından başlayalım
Mesela çorap renkli çoraplar giyebiliriz
yani onu da mesela Justin true'da çok
güzel bir şekilde onu başlattı siyasetçi
hiçbir zaman belki charlescotti
dönemlerine gitmeyeceğiz ama trado
renkli çoraplarını takımların altına
giymeye başladı ve benim geçen birkaç
hafta önce Brüksel'de katıldığım bir
toplantıda dünyanın her yerinden çok
sayıda Senatör renkli çoraplarla
gelmişti
bunun gibi küçük detaylarla
başlayabiliriz çünkü ancak hep beraber
Aslında bize dayatılan Bu kuralların ne
kadar keyfi ne kadar gülünç bundan 100
yıl önce bambaşka olduğunu hatırlar ve
hatırlatırsak hep birlikte
özgürleşeceğiz yani Bu kurallar meselesi
toplumsal cinsiyet meselesi bir kadın
meselesi değil bu hepimizin meselesi ve
özgürleşmek için gerçekten hep beraber
önce bunun ne kadar gülünç olduğunu ne
kadar keyfi olduğunu görüp Ondan sonra
da elimizden gelen mümkün olan küçük
adımlarla yola çıkabiliriz diyorum
seneye burada olursak
aramızda bu kodların dışında giyinmiş
çok fazla
izleyicinin olacağını düşünmek istiyorum
Çok teşekkür ediyorum İyi akşamlar
herkese
[Alkış]
[Kahkaha]
En azından böyle bir başlangıçta
apar topar bunu geçirdim Ama pantolon
olmasaydı İzmir'in bu sıcağında efil
efil Çok güzel olacağından emindim yani
tavsiye ederim erkeklere seneye gene
tedx olursa etekle çıkmazsam Hakan
Bilgin değilim buradan söylüyorum Hadi
bakalım